when people say happy holidays to me  around this time of year I go happy  holidays yeah and if they say Merry  Christmas I say oh happy Hanukkah it's  just like it's not a big deal I'm not  doing it aggressively it's just if they  wish me Merry Christmas because that's  what they celebrate I wish them happy  Hanukkah because that's what I celebrate  it's not a big deal no one has ever  gotten upset no one has ever gotten  offended it's it's kind of a joke but I  I do do that do that I'm not offended  nobody's offended it's really not a big  deal the thing that really does seem to  offend people  is these right Wingers when they are  told happy holidays they believe they  are being told happy holidays because  some woke Marxist leftists Obama yeah  like Obama or whoever right  has pressured uh a worker at Best Buy  to forego Merry Christmas and instead to  say happy holidays